- You called for backups?
- Teddy? Name's Hill.
I don't throw the football or line up under center.
I'm not old-fashioned like you.
- You are three years older than me.
- Coach says we have to play nice with him.
- ALL I WANTED TO BE WAS STARTER FOR LIFE!
- I want the both of you on this.
Everyone’s going to be so confused.
- Someone is taking out starters
based on the seven QB sins.
Greed.
Sloth.
- Oh, this is so comfy…
- Gluttony.
- I’m so hungry…
FOR KNOWLEDGE!
- Pride.
- I-I’ll be back when the Jags are in the playoffs!
- Lust.
- It was my first kiss…
- And envy.
- I JUST WANT THE REFS TO TREAT ME THE SAME.
- Now that’s only six.
- A REF.
KILL HIM!
- Uh-uh-uh!
There’s one more quarterback.
- Oh, you nutjob.
We lost good men and Big Ben.
- Don’t you see?
No quarterback
is greater than the almighty shield...
- What’s this?
Ahh!
The NFL has the upper hand.
- What’s in the box score?!
- It’s a six-game injury.
You guys only need to win like three games.
- NOOO!! THAT’S FOREVER!
- DON’T COMMIT PENALTIES.
THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS.
- [Ref blows whistle] HOLDING. ON THE OFFENSE.
- Vince Lombardi once said,
“Winners never quit, and quitters never win.”
I agree with the second part.
If you want to see more videos like this, subscribe to the channel.